das thema ja auf mallorca gab es
offenbar eine lage die außer kontrolle
geraten ist bei einer
restauranteröffnung gab es halt wieder
partys wie man sie aus dem letzten jahr
kennt und dabei haben wir ja jetzt
corona oder sofern machen sich alle so
ein bisschen sorgen was wird denn da
jetzt auf mallorca werden weder
weiterhin geordnet urlaub machen können
oder gerät tatsächlich die lager
auseinander fragezeichen wir wissen es
nicht genau
wir schauen uns dazu erstmal diese maz
an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja da wird gesungen und gegrölt so kennt
man es eigentlich von ballermann
eigentlich nichts spektakuläres nur wir
müssen sagen es war wirklich vor wenigen
tagen und das macht uns dann schon
sorgen weil wir wollen natürlich auch
vielleicht unsere mallorca urlaub wieder
genießen und solche bilder die stören
natürlich da außerdem ist gestern auch
die masken pflicht in kraft getreten und
darüber möchte ich spreche mit aris so
lies doch das ist unsere reporterin vor
ort also was war da genau los
bei dieser eröffnungsfeier
hallo frank
ja ich denke mal dass am freitag die
vielleicht die die lokale in der
bierstraße gar nicht mit so einem
grossen ansturm gerechnet haben
aber ja ein pakt beta wurde das auch
alles ein bisschen gesitteter es gibt
jetzt zum beispiel in dem lokal also
vorjahr gab in den eingriff in den
lokalen die schon eröffnet hatten gab es
sich julius und wir haben immer mal
geguckt und haben gesagt hier nicht
stehen mit wilden setzen
das gibt es jetzt in dem lokal was neu
eröffnet hat natürlich auch und jetzt
achten wie es ist schon ziemlich sehr
darauf also es gibt absperrungen damit
man auch genau sehen kann was gehört zu
den lokalen und was gehört jetzt
eigentlich veröffentlichen ihr strafe
damit man das alles ein bisschen mehr
kontrollieren kann
das heißt also sowas sollte sich nicht
wiederholen die spanier haben da
offenbar auch angst tatsächlich dass da
vielleicht lokale geschlossen werden
oder dass es dort weitere
einschränkungen gibt eine einschränkung
ist gestern in kraft getreten nämlich
eine relativ strenge masken pflicht was
hat es damit auf sich
genau gestern wurde ein diktat
veröffentlicht von einer etwas
strengeren macht nicht aber die stimmt
doch nicht so strengen denn am strang am
pool beim essen beim trinken beim
rauchen und an den promenaden muss man
irrt wenn man den sicherheitsabstand
gewährleisten kann von anderthalb metern
keine mast gefragt also nur überall da
wo man ein mindestabstand einhalten kann
das heißt also tatsächlich kann an der
promenade entlang marschieren und
braucht auch keine maske zu tragen ist
natürlich auch möglicherweise ein wenig
warm dabei 30 grad den ganzen tag eine
maske zu tragen
also du behältst dies geschehen im auge
und meldet sich bei bedarf wieder vielen
dank einstweilen und ich muss an
kempkens dazu nehmen natürlich da feiern
leute was den leuten natürlich auch zu
gönnen ist aber wo besteht da jetzt so
die große gefahr
naja das risiko ist im grunde genommen
wie auch in deutschland das bei einem er
bei einem erhöhten ansteckungsrisiko
dürfen die behörden nicht nur reagieren
sie müssen reagieren und das ist genau
das problem das ist auch so ein bisschen
so die ambivalenz in der sich die
behörden aus rechtsgründen ja befinden
das ist sehr umstritten wie geht man
jetzt weiter vor aber wenn bestimmte
grenzen überschritten werden dann müssen
die behörden dagegen steuern da darauf
haben sozusagen die nicht angesteckten
die anderen nur alle leute im grunde
genommen haben darauf einen anspruch
dass die behörden effektiv reagieren
und da besteht natürlich die gefahr wenn
jetzt die abstände unterschritten werden
und die ansteckungsrisiken sich wieder
erhöhen dass danach justiert wird und
zwar auch in spanien natürlich und das
heißt natürlich für menschen die ihren
urlaub gebucht haben die müssen dann
noch mit erheblichen einschränkungen
rechnen
absolut also es ist natürlich mit
erheblichen einschränkungen zu rechnen
das scheint ja auch ein bisschen
voranzuschreiten wenn wir diese bilder
sehen von der schinkenstraße von palma
de mallorca wo eben doch erheblich
gefeiert wird wo die leute eng
zusammenstehen und das muss dann
tatsächlich auch die behörden dazu
veranlassen etwas zu tun da wird auch
etwas passieren reiserechtlich bedeutet
das natürlich für alle leute die jetzt
da hinfahren dass sie sich weiter
einschränken müssen dass sie weiter
eingeschränkt werden und dass bestimmte
angebote die sie vielleicht auch mit
gebucht haben in ihren reise verträgen
dass sie jetzt gar nicht gar nicht
nutzbar sind und da wird man sich
sicherlich kurzfristig auf einige
einschränkungen vorbereiten müssen